can we say with certitude there's a deal
and there's a deal to bring back to
Congress in Washington there is
definitely a deal that news broke from
multiple delegations who we've been
covering here in Vienna for the last 19
days so for sure there is a deal we
actually have a copy of text of the deal
and we know several important things
from it one is that December 15th is the
target date by which Iran is supposed to
have taken all of the steps laid out to
limit its nuclear program and un
monitors from the IAEA need to verify
those steps and at that point Iran would
be eligible for bulk sanctions relief
which involves having their banks let
back into the Swift system having oil
sanctions removed and getting access to
almost 150 billion dollars in overseas
frozen assets so of course December 15th
big date that Iran is going to be
pushing forward none of the sanctions
relief will happen unless they IAEA you
know ticks the box that they've done all
these steps including resolve the
international community's questions
about the possible military dimensions
of Iran's path nuclear work so a lot of
Investigation busy months ahead if this
is going to go through indira looking at
the actual text of the deal and given
what you have heard from Congress over
the last six months can you handicap the
likelihood of this getting through
Congress look I think it's going to be
really hard to get a majority in
Congress approving the deal the Obama
administration on carry himself but also
the president's top advisers are going
to have a very big job ahead of them
going to Congress and in classified
setting and open setting trying to
explain why this is a good deal it put
the 10 year limit on enrichment by
Iranian it does many other things in
dear that is a bold statement by you I
know you've had no sleep what are the
consequences if Congress says to the
president and Tehran we're not going to
do this deal what happens next president
can veto that and so that's why they
ultimately even though I don't think
Congress will approve this view I don't
think they have a veto-proof majority to
reject it I don't think there's any
thirds of the Senate who is going to say
no to the Russian but I do think the
president may have
veto a majority saying no to this field
if you're a lot renown in Vienna this
morning of course is history's wait what
time was i too am just came out we need
to go to where there is a little bit of
pushback I speak lightly and we respect
for Israel they are not happy hour
Elliott got kin is in Tel Aviv Brendan
leadoff are questioning with Elliott
godkin this is heated response Elliott
Benjamin Netanyahu right out of the gate
obviously showing his disapproval of the
deal what leverage does he have right
now over the actual deal well Prime
Minister Netanyahu is going to be going
to Congress with which Indira was just
referring to and trying to ensure that
Congress does kill this deal will do its
best to kill a deal but Netanyahu
putting his opinions out there on
Twitter as he's so happy to do saying
that when willing to make a deal at any
cost this is the result from early
reports we can see that the deal is a
historic mistake in his deputy foreign
minister tzipi hot hot aveli went a
little bit further saying was a historic
capitulation by the west to the axis of
evil headed by Iran Elliott we've known
for a couple days that a deal is very
likely what does public opinion in
Israel look like on the on the terms as
we have them for the last elections here
showed that the country was was very
much divided between right and left but
I think one of the few things that many
Israelis agree upon whether they're on
the opposition or supporters of
Netanyahu's ruling coalition is that
they don't want Iran to get a nuclear
weapon they know that Iran has even
recently words from the Supreme Leader
talking about the destruction of Israel
and how that is a very how that is an
objective of avi ron and how that should
be an ejector objective of the world so
I think most Israelis and politicians of
all hues here are very much against Iran
getting a nuclear weapon where they
differ i think is the nuance is how to
deal with the US administration
particularly president obama to get
israel's point of view across well
Elliot you mentioned the president and
euro lachman on the president to speak
around seven a.m. this morning here in
about 50 minutes he will need to speak
to his Democrats as well as Republicans
obviously in opposition what does a
president need to say to his party
I think what he's going to say to the
American people is this is a historic
Accord that is preventing what has been
a rogue state from developing nuclear
weapons that's really the simple message
he needs to get out there he is to say
that this is going to stop a nuclear
weapons race in the Middle East that
it's going to bring peace and security
to the world of the middle age and he's
going to be selling that message very
hard to say this is a win for the United
States and the West not just a win for
Iran and getting it sanctions lifted
mandira last when I thank you so much
Elliot godkin as well and tell ivy